good morning John some days some days I
just want to be a professional internet
cat critic lasered wiggle cat lolled on
early example of the laser wiggle cat
genre is a humorous romp through
someone's living room a large-sized
unique aspect ratio and high frame rate
of this image magnificently captures
this cat's feverish determination but
the artistry of this image is not truly
apparent until you examine the tale big
butt cat stuck in box let's be honest
it's just a crude setup job by this
cat's human companion this person is
clearly aware of the largeness of the
but the smallness of the box and the
compulsiveness of this cat's desire to
be inside any kind of box well of course
not truly abusive I can't help but feel
a twinge of guilt with every giggle very
similar to how I feel about the classic
cat flirtation image bred face cat of
2009 this is not however how I feel
about the various cat leap fails
including the recent blockbuster loop
that's a beanbag these instances are
clearly the cat's decision and whether
or not there is a camera running at the
time the disaster that the Falls them is
their own doing cats of course always
emerge from these experiences unharmed
as they are apparently made of rubber
let's just be honest sometimes that's
what I want a simple life over analyzing
cats and looking at cute things and
being slightly witty and you know doing
things of questionable copyright
legality that would be a good job but it
would not be as good as my actual job
though sometimes it can be really
intense especially when it comes to the
VidCon planning times which is starting
to happen now 90 days out and this is
when it starts to get hard corey vidal
and alex carpenter and the apprentice
aid team are in town to film their
vlogging documentary i'm vlogging here
which i'm very excited about and it
looks like it's gonna be pretty freakin
good and i realized while talking to
them why being a professional cat critic
would not in fact be my dream job I like
to do different things every week and
that is such a tremendous luxury and yes
John you and I we have some
tried-and-true formats that we love and
then we go back to willingly and happily
but nerdfighter you never seem to expect
anything in particular from us except
that we don't make terrible content man
it appears to be make good stuff we
don't care what and that's the kind of
constraint that I'm very happy to work
inside of it I don't think that a lot of
creators get that kind of freedom so I'm
very grateful thank you all so cats man
freakin cute love those things John I
honestly don't know how you live your
life without a cat inside your house
it's like having a little living piece
of art that is also very warm and soft
thanks to everyone who's been watching
me vlog every day in April and Hanks
channel and of course thank you to all
the people who gave to the lizzie bennet
kickstarter a fifth top funded film and
video project of all time it was fourth
this morning but then Zach Braff decided
to do a thing thanks mr. Braff for
kicking us at the top for love scrubs I
really did like literally like when I
feel down that's the show i watch so I
wouldn't have wanted to be replaced by
anybody else couldn't think of a better
guy to give it to Jon I'm happy to get
to be the master to your doctor and I'll
see you on Tuesday